إنجاز كبير في السياسة الخارجية
للرئيس دونالد ترامب ورئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
في اتفاقية التطبيع هذه بين
إسرائيل والبحرين وبالطبع
يأتي في
أعقاب اتفاق التطبيع
اتفاق مشابه جدًا بين إسرائيل
والإمارات العربية المتحدة في جميع هذه البلدان الأربعة
ستكون الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل
والبحرين في الإمارات العربية
المتحدة في البيت الأبيض يوم الثلاثاء
لحضور حفل وتوقيع
اتفاقيات التطبيع هذه
وبالطبع لا يمكن التغاضي عن التوقيت
قبل شهرين من الانتخابات الأمريكية
التي يتخلف فيها ترامب في استطلاعات الرأي.  إنه
يبحث عن انتصارات وإنجازات في السياسة الخارجية ،
وهذا
بالتأكيد يندرج في تلك الفئة من
وجهات نظر معينة ،
ومن المفاجئ أن تكون البحرين مملكة سنية
في الخليج
وكان من المتوقع أن تقوم البحرين
بتطبيع الاتفاقات فقط إذا
فعل السعوديون أولاً
حتى يومنا هذا.
لا توجد علاقات دبلوماسية بين
الإسرائيليين ، لذا فإن البحرينيين
في هذه النقطة  على الأقل لم ينفجروا من
تلقاء أنفسهم دون
موافقة السعودية العلنية على الأقل ،
لكنه يثير تساؤلاً حول ما إذا كانت هناك
موافقة ضمنية
من جانب السعوديين ، لكن ربما
لا ينبغي أن يكون هذا مفاجئًا أن
البحرين كانت قريبة من البيت الأبيض.
ولسنوات
خلف الكواليس قريب جدًا من إسرائيل ،
لذا فإن هذه الاتفاقية
حتى لو كانت تؤتي ثمارها الآن
وخرجت إلى العلن كانت سنوات
وراء الكواليس في صنعها ،
حيث يترك هذا الفلسطينيون
قال ترامب إنهم مرحب بهم للحضور
مجلس إدارة في منطقة متغيرة ، وهي
منطقة تتحرك نحو
السلام العام بين إسرائيل
والدول العربية التي ستكون في إطار
رؤية البيت الأبيض للسلام
أو يبدو أن البيت الأبيض أكثر من
سعيد بتركهم وراءهم في
الشرق الأوسط المتغير
وارين ليبرمان سي إن إن القدس